people are more depressed more anxious  more suicidal and more addicted than  they were 30 years ago one of the main  reasons is because of this Relentless  pursuit of pleasure we live in a world  in which we are saturated with dopamine  and we live in a culture which  encourages us to pursue it but the  ultimate end result of pursuing dopamine  is to feel worse than when you started  and the three factors that make anything  more addictive are quantity potency and  Novelty and what our capitalist  technologically Innovative world has  created is an infinite quantity  incredible potency and endless novelty  and variety I mean addiction can happen  now in every realm of life it's almost  impossible to escape it